uh are anything else coming down the
pipeline obviously after tour uh you we
already know musically what's coming are
you going to be doing any clothes I'm
sure people can go buy merch definitely
doing clothes I got hella merch coming
out I got merch with leaks right now on
my tour and it's gonna be coming out
online soon and I'm just doing a whole
bunch of everything I'm definitely just
expanding what I do I already do close
and already make music so no I'm just
doing more of that it's like combining
them would you guys do
um because you know we always see uh
I think I like dream bills then revenge
of the dreamers a few times would there
be an opium
like compilation 100 we talk about our
entire win I can't [ __ ] tell you but
that's just definitely happening we're
like a gangster grills or something yeah
gangster girls would be crazy [ __ ] DJ
Drama if I can introduce him Playboy
cardi I don't know if I'm I don't know
if I'm built for that much energy on a
record I'm gonna be honest everybody is
yeah maybe yeah
I might have to pull up on the show
tonight come on man I'm gonna bring a
mouth guard you're welcome yeah bring a
mouth guard and help me probably some
football pads make sure you take your
old man underwear off put your [ __ ]
underwear on because it's gonna get
crazy yeah I'll wear something wait
what'd you say just put put your [ __ ]
piss oh bro okay what are those pants
you know what I'm saying probably like
some good jeans or something I'll just
take some drugs in take some drugs have
a good time you're definitely welcome
though I'll buy some Air Forces
pit Hey listen I mash bro modesty and
[ __ ] bro listen I don't think you
understand I'm [ __ ] I've I've [ __ ]
gotten laid out and laid people out in
mosh pits in my lifetime so you need to
be out there punching Autumn little kids
no no see that's the problem is there's
a bunch of [ __ ] 15 year olds and
they're they're [ __ ] 15. just find
you a good other what do you like 40
something I'm too old to lose now punch
him in the face I can't [ __ ] nobody up
in a mosh pit you can bro no I got two I
got too much [ __ ] to lose you scared
don't let it go viral like yo boo let go
knocked out a 17 year old dusty white
kid's teeth at a [ __ ] destroy lonely
show and uh he's been sued and he's good
then I'm gonna have to sell your merch
for you to [ __ ] pay off the debt you
know I ain't paying off [ __ ] I'd be
sitting at the [ __ ] show selling
merch in the [ __ ] Booth dude like a
[ __ ]
shout out to that guy by the way good
gig I'm telling you you punch out one of
them little kids they're gonna be like
[ __ ] put like a cab just punch me at the
destroy lonely show I actually believe
that dude I feel like y'all's fans are
[ __ ] they're like they for it bro
they want to punch me in the face yeah
let's bleed yeah thanks like [ __ ] yeah
obviously safely you know what I mean